[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to spectator TV I'm
Katie balls The Spectators political
editor and your host this week
Jeremy Hunt gave his Maiden budget this
week what's the shape of the UK economy
and Kate Andrews writes this week's
cover piece on the collapse of Silicon
Valley Bank obviously in a failure of
the banking system as a whole Kate will
join me with David Miles
Gus Carter writes in this week's
magazine that men are being damaged by
today's sexual politics he'll be on the
show with Nina power to discuss why men
are in crisis
Rishi sunak was in San Diego this week
for the launch of August the nucleus
submarine agreement between Australia
the U.S and the UK
is it a sign that war with China is
close I'll speak to Ike foramen as
Shashank Joshi
and finally Cosmo landisman has a secret
he used to pretend to be working class
why he'll join me to explain
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV then do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss an
episode ever again
and if you want to read more from The
Spectator then why not subscribe to the
magazine for just 12 pounds you can get
12 weeks in print and online and a free
20 pound Amazon voucher just go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash TV offer
to subscribe
first up
Jeremy Hunt gave his first budget this
week
pension allowances were slash there's
free child care and growth estimates for
revised upwards what does it all mean
I'm joined Now by Kate Andrew so
Spectators economics editor and David
Miles an economist who works at the obr
and was formerly at the bank of England
hey so we've had Jeremy Hunt's Maiden
budget as Chancellor and was it a good
news budget
uh good news bad news mixed bag really
the best news wasn't any particular
announcement that Jeremy Hunt made but
rather the forecast around it I'm sure
David can speak a bit to this but uh the
growth forecasts
um for the next few years are looking a
lot more positive than they were last
Autumn around an average of two percent
growth uh per year and the obr no longer
expects us to move into a technical
recession now for a lot of people this
doesn't really make a difference whether
or not the economy technically contracts
two quarters in a row it doesn't matter
as much as their standard of living
which the obr pointed out is expected to
fall quite significantly especially
because in terms of real wages with
inflation those are going down so people
might not feel all that better off but
it is a much better forecast than we had
before however the tax burden is on its
way to a post-war high in 2024 2025 the
obr expects that the public spending
ratio to GDP is going to look like it's
sustained around where we were in the
1970s Rishi c-neck and Jeremy Hunt are
presiding over a very big state and
their narrative is that they're doing it
responsibly but the truth is you know
the idea that with what they're
presiding over in their attitude towards
the state that at any point we're going
to get major tax cuts very hard to see
in a budget like this where he's
actually borrowing more money
David the obr analysis as ever was
pretty sobering
um what were your main takeaways
well I think Kate's right I mean in the
near terms there's a bit of good news
relative to where we were back in
November the main thing really is that
gas prices have fallen so so much and
where they look like they're going over
the next year or so is a heck of a lot
lower
good for government spending because
it's less expensive to offer the
guarantees the price guarantees it's
good for households because it means
that the hit to real disposable income
which is still big
is a bit less big than it would have
been it's particularly useful on
inflation
so it looks now to us anyway our Central
estimate informed guests is probably the
best way of putting it is that inflation
might get down to a little bit under
three percent by the end of the year
coming from just a couple of months ago
11 so that's a really big fall that's
very helpful to the government as well
in the short term because it reduces the
cost of a big chunk of government debt
which is this index linked inflation
linked uh government bonds can I ask
David quickly on that because I was take
my job I'm so sorry I'm going to abuse
my position in the seat and and just
quickly as I was so startled by that
forecast because I think that's the most
optimistic one I've seen that by the end
of the year we could actually be quite
close to the bank's Target whereas in
our current inflation figure we get an
update very soon but you know still in
double digits so I was wondering if you
could just talk a little bit more about
the obr's forecast around that yes it's
it's largely because of this falling in
gas prices
which over the course of this year if
you just use what the market expects the
level of gas prices going to be the
Futures price that's something like 50
lower than it was in November
so that really brings the inflation rate
down quite sharply and it brings it down
sharply more quickly than we thought
before so we'd always thought that
inflation was likely to fall back to the
bank of England's Target but probably
not until the middle of next year now
that looks like it it's almost happened
by the end of
this year I think the reason why the obr
forecast looks a bit more optimistic
than most other people is that ours is
for the moment anyway the most recent
forecast so we were able to use the
Futures prices on gas as they were a
couple of weeks ago
for example the bank of England's last
forecast was you know six or seven weeks
ago they were looking at where gas
prices were forecast by the market to be
seven or eight weeks ago and things have
moved a lot
and David what about the Fallen living
standards um because I think that was a
probably one of the areas where you have
lots of the spin from Jeremy Hunt
although it's going to improve but this
is quite significant and how will
consumers feel it
it's a big fall we think it's something
of the order of six percent decline in
real disposable incomes the average
household in the UK over two years
that's historically a very dramatic fall
it's largely a result of where we're
coming from which is just there's been
this huge increase in the price level
you know it's the 11 inflation and wage
settlements haven't kept up with it and
the tax take is creeping up partly
because
the kind of indexation of the tax system
has been frozen so more people are
moving into higher tax rates so it's a
combination of those things just
squeezing householding I mean it's
almost inevitable when there has been
such a big
increase in the cost of things that we
significantly important to the UK and
there's no there's no somebody's got to
take the hit for that and it ends up one
way or another with households the big
number though isn't it three million
dragged into tax full stop and then an
additional 2 million dragged into a
higher rate it is it's significant
um and what the government's trying to
do of course is is try and bring the
deficit down and it's it's got a sort of
twin track approach in a way
government spending as a share of GDP
which has been extraordinarily High
merely falls back to historically high
levels that's actually falling tax take
is rising because you're trying to
squeeze the gap between the two to drive
the deficit down so the stock of debt
just doesn't keep on going up no it's
one of the situations where you know
it's the old cliche you know you
wouldn't want to start from here but
here's where you have to start from
um and Kate before we turn to your cover
piece and and The Wider picture
um ultimately a really large chunk of
the budget was about the out of work
which falls into you know three groups
there's some benefits the over 50s
um Jeremy Hunt next many are on the golf
course and then those who are tanning
down work because of child care costs
can you just talk us through how Jeremy
Hunt is trying to tackle this and
whether you think it's going to have
much of an impact so on pensions he's
scrapping the lifetime allowance on
benefits labor is opposing British labor
is opposing specifically I think because
they don't want it to apply to everyone
they want it specifically to apply to
doctors or they want it to be more
narrow it's disproportionately uh
doctors and Healthcare professionals who
are in that bracket anyway then yeah
well and and the labor right to point
out that you have to be earning a lot of
money if you're reaching that limit
um but I think the argument on the other
side is you know if it's a little it's a
little tricky and a little technical to
start signaling out professions then on
child care you have the additional
subsidy 30 uh free hours a week for
families in a larger bracket and then on
benefits you have a range of proposals
including a new Universal support scheme
and the idea that this can help more
drive people back into work now I think
what's quite telling from the obr's
figures is that we're talking about tens
maybe if we're lucky hundreds of
thousands of people or just over 100 000
people being affected by the range of
these schemes a spectator has shown
through its day to have their 5.2
million people on some kind of out of
work benefit right now and job vacancies
remain at over a million and the big
question for Jeremy Hunt is I think
individually some of these measures are
quite good especially getting rid of the
distortions around pensions Child Care
is a bigger question because he's going
to be creating even more Demand with
these so-called free hours in a market
that's very tight there's not loads of
supply and that might actually drive up
the cost for people who fall outside of
these 30 hours what that will do to
women getting back to work in particular
I don't know but whatever these measures
do it doesn't really begin to tackle
that 5.2 million figure and so you know
the question for the government in a
relatively short period of time is are
we going to see these improvements but
to what extent will we actually be
getting people back into work it's
wonderful for every person who's able to
go back you know who who who's able to
better their life in that way but
um there's it seems from these schemes
there's still going to be a lot of
people left out of that Katie I'm David
do you think I have to get used to
having a high number out of work
well
I mean you're right the the the measures
that we were considering at the obr we
thought had a meaningful but not
dramatic impact on labor Supply four or
five years down the road I mean
something like 110 000 it's a bit more
than that because the child care
measures also we think increase the
number of hours worked for mothers who
are already working but they just get
more generous child care it's likely
that some will work more so it's a bit
more than just 110
000.
the the the the sort of conditionality
and trying to get people who are on
benefits back into work strategy was
when it was it was actually quite
difficult for us to score that firmly
because the evidence base is not strong
enough yet it's clear what the intention
of the government is that it may it may
play out over a longer a longer time
Horizon if I might just say on the
pensions thing I think it is the
lifetime allowance it's more than just
doctors because there's
possibly four or five hundred thousand
people in the UK
who we estimate within the next five
years would have got close to the one
million pound lifetime allowance limit
and it was more about how many of those
people if a lifetime allowance limit has
gone face less of a
this less of a disincentive to leave
work
so it was more about them than just
about doctors and I think that's right
by the way I I'm not really sure the
state should be picking and choosing
which professions get the tax benefit
um now onto your cover piece okay you
write and spectator this week about a
new age of economic uncertainty
talk us through it I'm sorry to say
there's yet another one
um but actually this topic in the cover
this week takes us back to a budget a
few years ago when Rishi sunak in his
March 2021 budget still really around
the height of lockdowns in covid but we
were being vaccinated
um was really looking at that budget not
from the perspective of you know a wide
range of policy but rather from his fear
that even a small change to the
inflation rate or interest rates to
follow to try to tame inflation could
really send the public finances into a
spiral and at the time he was thinking
you know what if interest rates go up by
say one percent
um at the in the UK the base rate is now
at four percent uh you know throughout
many countries interest rates have had
to go up very quickly in order to tackle
double-digit inflation and because of
that we are now discovering what this
denial around ultra low interest rates
for the past decade this assumption on
the part of virtually everyone that
rates were going to be low for long what
kind consequences that has created and
you've seen very recently the collapse
of the Silicon Valley Bank which was you
know so tied up in government bonds that
its interest rates Rose and the those
bonds fell in value there was a run on
the bank but actually in the UK you can
go back to the ldi pension scare last
year which was also linked to Market
worries that interest rates were going
to go up really quickly after that mini
budget and what I try to point to in the
piece is that we are talking talking
about historically very normal interest
rates an interest rate for four or five
percent is not historically a high
interest rate but we are starting to
discover these land mines that have been
hiding underneath the economy businesses
sectors that cannot deal with higher
interest rates and that's actually quite
worrying because not only could there be
meaningful crises to come down the road
but we don't totally know where they are
especially on those ldi Pension funds
for example House of Lords report that
was published last month you know this
was a regulated sector this this this is
a highly assessed sector and the broad
consensus was these are fine because
they never expected interest rates to go
to anywhere like they ended up David I
was quite struck by Kate's piece in the
sense that I think it is one thing for
consumers to be surprised by interest
rates going up so you know first-time
buyers and perhaps people in my
generation here quite used almost had
grown up for these historically low
interest rates and they think it's
normal and now they're getting a nasty
surprise but you would expect new
professionals and these businesses when
they're making their decisions to be
aware of the fact this could happen what
do you think has gone wrong
I think what's happened is that and
maybe it's easy to see this in
retrospect than at the time I think
central banks have made a mistake
frankly
which is so Keen have they been to
reduce
the worry that people might think they
were about to put interest rates up
sharply
that they've reinforced a view that
these interest rates which have been
until very recently it's historically
extraordinarily low levels so under
myself being very keen to give the
impression that this is how things are
very likely to stay for a long time
they've adopted various versions of
forward guidance I mean the ECB in
particular
thinking that it is an essential part of
their role to say what they think the
next several years will be not just the
next few months and the message has been
until inflation really picked up a few
months ago very sharply
maybe a year ago the message until then
was these rates are going to stay very
long for a very long period of time so
it's not entirely surprising then that
when rates do go up
by historically not very large amounts I
mean Kate's completely right the level
of interest rates in the UK at four
percent is below the 300 year average
Bank of England rate which is about five
percent so it's not that we're at
extraordinarily High interest rates it's
that people were encouraged I think to
believe that they would not rise
significantly at all
at least over any time Horizon that
mattered I think that that's been
frankly a sort of policy error
okay and we're now in a situation where
lots of people are trying to work out
where the next horror is lurking we had
the Silicon Valley Bank there's Credit
Suisse can you talk us through what's
going on there
there were Jitters this week when credit
suisse's stock shares fell by 20 I think
it hit a historic low
um and there was a lot of worry you know
is this the next in the chain following
the Silicone Valley Bank closure but you
know it is rebounding it doesn't seem to
be the situation that some people
thought it was at the start of the week
um but the Jitters are legitimate in the
sense that nobody really knows the
standing of a lot of Institutions at the
moment and we've got a great piece to go
alongside the cover this week written by
Julian Jessup a sort of a bit of a
package he he looks at what could be
next and he talks about government debt
he talks about the housing market both
commercial and you know individual homes
he looks at a range of things and the
real concern is that having kept
interest rates so low as long as we did
things could be bubbling up with you
know that have been bubbling for 10
years for five years for a really long
period of time but his piece kind of
goes into the details of what we might
be looking at and David just finally
then is it time to panic
it's always it's always worrying when
banks that are sort of big names and
credit species is a big name get into
trouble I mean it's not entirely news
because they've been in trouble for
quite a lot along
nonetheless it makes people look at
pretty much all banks and say what do we
not know about them I think the one
reason to feel somewhat reassured but it
is a big reason is the following
just before the global financial crisis
in the UK the banks collectively held
deposits or so-called Reserves at the
central bank at the bank of England
which added up to a bit less than 30
billion pounds
they now have 900 billion pounds
in the in some sense that is a side
effect of quantitative easing because
that's what happens when the Central
Bank buys stuff
and hands out money to pay for it and
they've been buying government bonds and
that money flows through the banking
system and it ends up back in the Bank
of England
so you have a banking system in the UK
with 900 billion pounds of cash
if there's worries about a particular
bank that they can draw upon and it's
sort of guaranteed to use
there was virtually nothing in the UK
banking system at the bank of England in
2008 which is why
when people got worried it was a crisis
immediately
thank you David thank you Kate
Gus Carter The Spectators Deputy
features editor writes in this week's
magazine that men are in crisis to
explain he joins me now with Nina power
Economist at Compact magazine
Gus Nina thank you for joining spectator
TV this week Gus you write in the
magazine that young boys are in a bind
tell us why
well I think the argument that I make in
the magazine is that young boys are
basically faced with a new form of
sexual politics which treats them as
though they're inherently dangerous to
girls and young women that treats them
as though they basically can't control
their instincts and we see this in
adverts on the tube there are signs that
say uh unwanted staring is sexual
harassment and that kind of thing but
there are also these groups going into
schools that are talking to young boys
and they're saying uh basically
masculinity is something that needs to
be changed and they're saying again we
need to stop violence against women and
girls all things that are you know
perfectly good and proper everyone
agrees with that I think the problem is
that is that in some ways the pendulum
is swung to such an extent that boys
feel like they can't express any form of
masculinity really Nina do you think
that young men in the west are being
unfairly vilified yeah I think we've
actually been seeing this for quite a
few years now it's often kind of a
media-led campaign to sort of divide the
Sexes and to present this kind of
um ongoing sense of Suspicion it's also
in the broader context of kind of
safetyism
um and I think also a kind of lack of a
general moral code sort of following the
the death of religion if you like so
nobody really knows how to behave with
each other anymore and I think this has
given rise as a kind of paranoia which
has largely been aimed at men and and as
Gus says they're sort of supposed or
purported inability to contain
themselves
and Gus where do you think the problem
is starting or I suppose stemming from
here because one thing she write in your
piece about is um what children being
told in schools so there's one example
of I think just a boy messaging a girl
apparently that's a problem yes I mean
that's an extraordinary story from a
friend who's whose son is at a his son's
at a an English Day School uh and he
texted a girl from another school
basically just saying hello uh and he
was called up in front of the school
authorities to explain his behavior uh
for the criminal act of unsolicited
contact uh with a with a girl I think I
think the problem here is that um you
know children need to be exposed to to
uh different elements
all different parts of kind of adult
life right that's part of growing up
people need to learn how to have
relationships people need to learn how
to deal with the kind of messiness of of
human life and what we're doing is we're
denying children that opportunity and I
think it's turning them into into
slightly kind of uh scared sad and
withdrawn individuals and I think it's a
problem particularly with boys but I
mean I mean Nina Nina made the point
that uh that that it's kind of pitting
the Sexes against each other that's
totally true I mean you know this isn't
an argument that that somehow uh you
know girls or women are mistreating men
that isn't it at all it's more a kind of
culture as Nina says of of safetyism
and then on that do you think that what
we're seeing here is when we talk about
rebranding masculinity is there a risk
at least some of the people saying that
is just almost ending masculinity and
replacing it more with femininity
yeah I I think that that's definitely
happening and it goes alongside the kind
of feminization of the economy as well
and the sort of devaluing of sort of
traditionally or typically male
interests and talents and skills
um so that everyone almost is being
pushed towards becoming more more
feminine which isn't good for men and it
isn't good for women either actually
um so that we end up with this kind of
totally proximate society in which men
and women are kind of almost like
siblings rather than in any uh more
interesting relation let's say of like
compatibility or companionship or
um you know like complementarity you
know we don't we don't kind of think of
the relationship between men and women
um in that way very often which is which
is unfortunate because in a way that is
what we need to get along you know
whether it's as friends or as as married
couples or you know and that there's not
enough value or time given to that to
those kind of um relations I think and
Gus I suppose on that we can talk about
uh those who've got plenty examples in
your piece who are um ultimately in a
way you could argue trying to end
masculinity as opposed to
um rebranding and what their real motive
is but of course you also have concerns
and perhaps what we see more in the
media that there is something called
talks masking into so for example if you
look at Andrew Tate that is someone that
had teachers have been really concerned
about
um they think you know lots of uh you
know you are average person on the
street they might not know who that
person is or they may now have recent
stories
um but yet that person was very well
known amongst pupil age and it is
teaching boys bad attitudes do you think
there's a problem then I suppose with uh
on the side of messenger that there are
some people who are putting forward a
toxic version of it oh totally I totally
agree with that I mean you know if you
look at some of the things Andrew Tate
says they're just I mean totally
objectionable that you know it's not an
argument about about defending people
like Andrew Tate but I but I think I
think what's happened is that is that
you've had other people people like uh
Jordan Peterson people like Joe Rogan
who do exude a form of a form of
masculinity and put forward a kind of
vision of masculinity and those people
are treated as kind of extremists too I
think you can disagree with people like
like Jordan Peterson I certainly don't
think he's an extremist but part of the
problem is when you treat those kinds of
people in that way you give rise to uh
to a kind of to an even kind of further
more extreme kind of thing yeah exactly
exactly and I think that's part of the
problem you know I mean it's one of
those things that's that's kind of
that's often decried in the media the
fact that there aren't you know very
many male role models anymore but when
they do pop up I mean they are they are
kind of ruthlessly attacked and and so
the boys you know go looking for
something even more kind of extreme and
mental Nina do you agree with that
yes I mean I would say someone like
Andrew Tate
um could be seen as a kind of symptom
you know he's subversive and attractive
precisely because partly he's saying
things that you're not really allowed to
say according to the mainstream dominant
regime ideology
um you know which isn't to defend Andrew
Tate at all and I think you know I agree
with um Gus in the sense that even very
moderate and Mild
um positions like Jordan Peterson's
which is basically fundamentally telling
young men to sort of sort themselves out
and stop blaming the world and women for
their problems and just get things in
order which is you know really kind of
basic stuff but you know delivered in
this kind of patrician 1950s absent
father figure which I think is a big
part of the problem
um kind of way and I I think what's
what's generally missing is the question
of virtue like there isn't enough room
to say what does it mean to be a good
man right so figures like men like Tate
are presenting well this is how you get
on in the world through status and and
being I don't know really quite uh and
unpleasant
um but what we really need is just kind
of men
um well the possibility for men and
young boys to be good rather than this
kind of fundamental assumption that
there's something wrong with men or that
you know boys and men are fundamentally
badly aligned or you know which which
can't be the case right if we want to
get on together we have to allow that
both men and women are moral agents as
well and so therefore we can talk about
what it means to be a good man and what
it means to be a good woman
um and what it means to be together in a
better way basically Nina I'm really
interested in your point about about
virtue and about ethics I think there
was an interesting item in in Charles
Moore's notes last week when he pointed
to uh and this is a bit of a kind of
side comment but uh uh where where he
pointed to the Civil Service where
they're hiring kind of Ethics officers
and there's almost this sense of of kind
of ethics and virtue being something
that's done by Specialists now rather
than something that we all have to deal
with in our own lives and when you do
that when you remove it something else
is going to come in and fill the Gap we
just don't we just kind of don't even
think about it in in moral terms
no exactly it's a total absence you know
and I think it's part of being in a kind
of post-christian
um very mixed world that's also filled
with very contradictory imperatives like
if you know young men are often watching
a lot of pornography I mean that gives
you a vision of the world which is like
overwhelmingly sexual you know and a lot
of young men then start to see the world
in that way you know exhibit and
experience shame they can't interact
normally
um but we need a much more kind of
integrated culture that says look
they're all these things you could
possibly do but some of them are
actually bad for you and they're bad for
society as a whole you know we don't try
we don't tend to think in that kind of
socially integrated way we we think that
everything is an individual decision
because and that desire is good and
whatever people want is good
um but this is this selfishness this
selfish Society
um yeah completely mitigates against any
Collective project of virtue
so Gus watching the answer is here when
it comes to stopping this group feeling
uh as low they are being isolated or and
they've been pushed you know further in
a certain direction is it less
interference I don't really know it's
it's I kind of didn't get into it in the
piece and I almost did that on purpose
because I don't know what the answers
are I think if there was someone here uh
kind of disagreeing with me and Nina
they would be saying but hang on there's
a there's a huge problem with with
sexual assault you know I talk to my
female friends and they say you don't
realize what it's like to sit on the to
sit on the tube on your own you know
you're constantly bombarded by by men
you know behaving inappropriately and I
and I I totally understand that it seems
like a very seems like a very difficult
problem to solve I think I think part of
the way of doing it though is is
allowing people the space to kind of
make mistakes almost so the woman that
started everyone's invited which is the
movement that kind of led to a lot of
these uh like Boyhood initiatives and uh
you know a lot of discussions about
toxic masculinity uh and it came about
because uh there were a lot of uh
accusations of sex assault at kind of uh
big English private schools she said
when she launched it she didn't want it
to become kind of cover for for cancel
culture she didn't want she didn't want
children to be kind of attacked for
making mistakes she just said she wanted
people to recognize that there was a
problem and and you know in order to in
order to kind of better deal with it but
it shouldn't have been a kind of cancel
culture thing and I think I think maybe
that's that's where we're going wrong
you know I mean there's a there's an
example I use in the piece of a School
in Essex where they've totally banned
children from having any romantic
relationships from even from even
touching each other even hugs and that's
clearly a sign of a of a you know of an
institution that's that's terrified of
you know of people making mistakes of
people getting upset people being
unhappy that's part of being in
relationships
and you know I suppose on Gus's point
which is you know lots of people will
say well look at all these examples in
the past in terms of Men Behaving Badly
um you look at harassment rates and so
forth
um you do need to have the way to stop
this is to you know try and stem the
problem early on Hensley's talks in
schools
um so what would you say to them
yeah I think it's it's I agree with Gus
that there's this kind of we have to
allow people to make mistakes I mean we
all make mistakes and a lot of things
are not badly intended right you know
there's obviously a difference between
somebody kind of intentionally
um
of setting somebody or or behaving in a
way that's kind of uh clearly goes
against their wishes but most of the
time in a lot a lot of these kind of
interactions especially among teenagers
they're more Awkward than badly intended
I think and you know to lump everything
in together is and to kind of
infantilize everyone and keep them
protected and keep them safe isn't going
to allow people to become mature and
become adult which is partly uh arrived
at through making mistakes and that goes
for girls and boys as well you know I
mean it's not only boys uh making
mistakes
um so I think yeah we're going to end up
with a kind of culture of of permanent
children who are sort of very scared and
over protected
um and I think this isn't really the way
to pursue seed it doesn't set you up for
dealing with the reality of life and
it's inevitable suffering in fact trying
to keep people from suffering actually
makes them suffer more right so I you
know again it's a very complicated uh
question I mean I read um uh Soma
Sarah's book and and looked at the
everyone's invited project
um and really the only conclusion you
could draw from the kind of terrifying
paint picture that she paints of what
it's like to be at schools is to to go
to single sex schools and to keep boys
and girls completely segregated until
they're about 21 or something I mean
it's really what she's describing as a
kind of horrific environment filled with
uh you know uh boys just completely
influenced by pornography and you know
it that may be worse that may be worse
than it was when we were at school
um you know I'm not going to deny that
you know having porn on your phone is is
maybe more uh yeah of course it's a
different it's a different world in some
ways
um but I think the conclusion uh can't
necessarily be that kind of total
segregation you know then we're back to
almost like a religious Society uh
almost a theocracy and we might need
better ways of of young men and women
spending time together we might need
more
um thought about what rituals we have
right but I think we're looking at a
very
um kind of imbalanced picture either
total segregation or this kind of
liberal free-for-all
um and neither of which seem
particularly satisfying I was going to
say Nina on your on your point about
infantilization uh and about making
people more anxious by trying to stop
them from suffering I think we kind of
risk going into a bit of a a bit of a
death spiral here in a way because and
I'm going to say something quite kind of
controversial but I think uh I think
part of the problem is that there's been
a massive expansion in the definition of
what of what kind of sexual misconduct
is in the first place so if you look at
um if you look at statistics on sex
assault in schools uh from about 10 15
years ago it's much much lower than the
figures uh were in 2021 and I think part
of that is because definitions are
changing and definitions are expanding
and then that and then that seems to
almost encourage uh this kind of culture
to go further if you see what I mean
yeah for sure
and Gus just finally
we're obviously at a period where um
we're still talking about school boys
particularly we've had the pandemic
which has meant even less social
interaction than these people would have
normally I think as Nina was touching on
um if you are you know lurking in chat
rooms watching porn and you're not
actually speaking to people
um this idea you know that is one form
of segregation and of itself do you
think
um despite all these attempts to almost
keep boys and girls separate that more
interaction is actually the answer to
normalize these relationships oh totally
uh and it's a form of self uh
self-segregation uh is the boys kind of
kind of withdrawing themselves I think
because of uh because of this feeling
that they can't really get anything
right at all it's a lot easier to just
sit in your bedroom for you know most of
your teens and 20s you know you're not
going to get in trouble with anyone uh
you sat there having a rather sad life
sat in your bed um one of the people I
speak to in the piece is a is a child
psychologist called Julie Lynn Evans and
when I spoke to her she said uh the
problem here is that um is that boys and
girls are being kind of pitted against
each other and
um girls are being told boys are
dangerous boys are being told you know
you're a danger unto yourself and others
uh and actually it's it's just it's
untrue and it's unhelpful the girls want
boyfriends as much as the boys want
girlfriends and you know if we're going
to continue as a society people need to
you know get married have kids that's
how we that's how we continue as a
species
it's also important to the future of
mankind yeah exactly exactly thank you
Gus thank you Nina for joining spectator
TV
Rishi enactment with Joe Biden Anthony
Albanese this week to finalize the
details of the orcus nuclear submarine
pact Ike Freeman director of
indo-pacific a green mantle advisory
firm writes in this week's magazine
about how Britain can do even more to
help combat China in the Pacific to
discuss he joins me now with Shashank
Joshi defense editor at The Economist
thank you for joining spectator TV this
week
um just to begin the conversation like
how seriously should we take the threat
that China poses to Taiwan
I think the answer is very seriously
indeed China regards Taiwan as an
existential issue a question of
historical Justice uh and the resolution
of the Civil War that ended in 1949. uh
China is also afraid not unreasonably
that many people on Taiwan want to
formalize taiwan's de facto independence
by striking some sort of political
arrangement with the United States so
even if China is not planning an
outright invasion of Taiwan China needs
to dial up the military pressure on both
Taiwan and the United States to make
sure that they're deterred from doing
this
and Sasha when it comes to force how can
we compare what China has
um not just to Taiwan because I think we
probably could work out the answer to
that but you know what allies would
offer such as America potentially if we
did you know face a potential standoff
I think the point is that the Gap is
been growing dramatically in the last 10
years or so
um particularly in the naval realm
China's Navy is the biggest in the world
between 2014 and 2018 It produced
vessels of more tonnage than the entire
Indian Navy or French Navy in total
which gives you a sense of just how
gargantuan that buildup IS and in some
areas notably in conventional missiles
but also air defense and certain other
areas we're seeing a significant Chinese
advantage and I think the challenge for
the Americans is
um how do they make sure that the air
bases they've traditionally had in
countries like Japan
um survive in the face of a big
onslaught of missiles so they're working
extremely hard to try and disperse those
forces as widely as possible and when
we're looking at obviously the big
announcement this week when it comes to
August
um you had you know I think two of the
original leaders at the time when August
was first about and now moved off and we
haven't leaders in their place and but
the agreement stays strong and how's
that do you think I'm impacting all this
in the sense it's a big boost to Taiwan
I think that August is more about
Australia's security and essential role
in the emerging architecture of
indo-pacific regional security than it
has about Taiwan Australia hasn't
committed in advance to participating in
any defensive exercises around Taiwan
nor have they committed to participating
in a war and I think that's probably
sensible for Australia's national
interests I think it's also a question
whether the UK would want to participate
it would depend on the context of how a
Taiwan War were to come about that said
I think it's definitely in the interest
of the United States Britain and
Australia to tighten their collaboration
in high-tech military uh high-tech
military development and in exercises
because the more tightly relevant
countries are in the region intertwined
in a vision for a secure and stable
indo-pacific
the more China is likely to be deterred
from causing trouble
I think Ike is right but all I'd say is
that I think it is looking increasingly
difficult politically that Australia
could stay out of a war over Taiwan in
the same way that I think it would be
increasingly difficult for Japan to stay
out of a war
um it's you know these navies are going
to be integrated America is going to be
increasingly reliant on um bomber bases
in the north of Australia submarine
ports in the west of Australia
um and the politics of turning around to
America in what would be the biggest war
since 1945 and saying sorry we're
sitting this one out to me that just
seems implausible for Europeans it's a
slightly different issue but even for us
I think we're going to find it
increasingly hard to say we're sitting
this one out
saw a situation where effectively I mean
Beijing uh have voiced their unhappiness
over their orcas announcement so you
have a situation where yes Taiwan itself
uh you know perhaps not you know is not
a key part but the general sense uh
particularly perceived in China of
aggression towards China and does it
does I think probably have an effect in
making China think about its options
active uh you know they once hope that
Taiwan could be unified with the
mainland by peaceful means by economic
absorption trade ties economic ties
social ties what's actually happened is
Taiwanese people look at the fate of
Hong Kong
um and understand you know that's not
what we would like
um they they increasingly identify as
Taiwanese rather than Chinese in terms
of their identity and so that has pushed
the Chinese into a more radical position
but I think as much as we prepare for a
potential military conflict with China
uh and deter the Chinese there's also an
acute sense we also want to deter Taiwan
from anything rash we've been very lucky
to have a Taiwanese president for the
last several years who has been very
pragmatic and sensible who hasn't pushed
for anything radical anything that's
rocked the boat substantially that may
not be the case for the next 10 years
and so from an American perspective a
European perspective this isn't just
about deterring the Chinese it's also
about making sure the Taiwanese uh don't
do anything that dramatically changes
their status and their position across
the street
like on Taiwan could you just explain to
viewers what the Strategic significance
of Taiwan is particularly we're talking
about for example semiconductors
well Taiwan is essentially important to
the architecture of security in the
broader region and it starts with
geography itself general Douglas
MacArthur uh who commanded U.S forces in
the Pacific uh in World War II once
called Taiwan an Unsinkable aircraft
carrier in the first island chain if you
look at a map you can trace a line of
islands down from the Japanese
archipelago to Taiwan and the
Philippines uh down to Indonesia and
Australia the U.S concept for how to
maintain order in the Pacific since 1945
has been to maintain a network of bases
and relationships on those islands
because it's very hard to take an island
with an amphibious Invasion across an
ocean this represents a line of defense
that contains at first Russian and now
Chinese expansion outward it's also very
important from a naval point of view
because if you look on a map you may not
notice this but you have to look at a
topographic map it's actually very
difficult to get ships out from within
that first island chain right off of
China's coasts into the wider Waters of
the Pacific this is important for naval
ships and especially submarines if the
United States and Taiwan are working
together especially with Japan and the
Philippines they can largely contain the
Chinese Navy to just a hundred miles or
so off of its coasts but if China is
able to take control of Taiwan they can
project Naval power outward they can
threaten time they can threaten Japan
they can threaten to encircle and
blockade the Philippines and all of a
sudden they are able to project forces
much further into the Pacific even
threatening the United States Homeland
so that's the geographic reason why
Taiwan matters but Taiwan also matters
because it's become an essential
component of this integrated high-tech
global economy over 90 percent of the
world's Advanced semiconductors are made
in Taiwan and semiconductors make our
modern world run everything from Autos
to iPhones the United States obviously
can't let these facilities fall into
Chinese hands and in fact they've
communicated that if they're World War
uh the Americans would destroy these
facilities rather than lose control of
them but from China's perspective if the
United States is going to cut off their
access to these facilities anyway
it might be better to strike Taiwan just
to level the playing field so this is
the quandary the U.S needs to preserve
its competitive advantages in
collaboration with allies but the
various steps that it could take to
preserve those advantages could
incentivize China to strike
on semiconductors are we seeing Western
countries such as America take steps
when it comes to obviously having
self-sufficiency in terms of their own
supplies
they're certainly trying to achieve that
but it's extremely difficult because
this is a field in which the capital
investment necessary to produce
semiconductors particularly the the Fabs
that sort of produce these things
um is enormous absolutely enormous you
know staggering amounts the Technologies
are highly concentrated and so you know
for example in terms of uh lithography
one of the key techniques in the
production of semiconductors
um it's asml in the Netherlands which
has absolutely vital expertise so it
isn't just you know as if America has
everything it needs
um yes America has is you know it's past
laws trying to onshore some of this
production and there are very sound
reasons you don't want to depend for
your entire Economic Security and
semiconductor supply chain on a small
island that is within range of
um many thousands of Chinese missiles at
risk of invasion
um but I have to say that however much
you invest in this however however hard
you try and however much you talk to the
South Koreans and the Japanese and
others and try and put production
facilities back in the United States
you're still going to be quite dependent
for the foreseeable future on tsmc which
is this Flagship Taiwanese semiconductor
firm and I think it raises some
fascinating questions you know thinking
more perhaps um in Macabre fashion as to
if there was an invasion
um what would the US Taiwan and others
do in terms of considering the
destruction of those facilities to avoid
them falling into the hands of the
Chinese government
and I I remember in previous interviews
when we talked about Ukraine for example
often Taiwan comes up and that
definitely was I think uh growing
consensus amongst uh you know some
experts on the issue they thought uh how
Russia having impacted by the invasion
of Ukraine would put china off actually
um trying to take Taiwan do you think
that's still seen as the case or
actually it does feel so alarm is
growing and you know up to this point
more so
the Ukraine issue is complex and it has
had both pros and cons for China on
balance I think it's quite clear that
the the the cons outweigh the pros from
China's perspective uh the war in
Ukraine has shown that Western Unity is
possible it's shown that a military
force that is well funded that is
considered by many around the world to
be uh an extremely impressive fighting
force can collapse in operational
mismanagement and be held at Bay by a
much smaller adversary
from China's perspective I think this
should seriously call into question the
fighting ability of the people's
Liberation Army which let's face it
hasn't fought a major war since 1979 and
is mostly thinking about this Invasion
through studying in books so from
China's perspective there have been some
advantages for example Russia having
been largely cut off from the U.S
financial system having been forced
through this oil price cap scheme to
sell its oil at a much discounted price
has provided some economic advantages to
Chinese industry and it's put Russia in
a position of geostrategic submission
where it essentially has to listen to
China's uh requests more seriously and
potentially uh do what China asks Russia
would be an essential partner for China
in any Taiwan contingency and season
ping recognizes this which is why he
hasn't thrown Putin under the bus but
that said if I'm season paying uh the
the external environment that I faced
today okay in terms of the unity of
purpose in my adversaries is much more
unfavorable than it was on February 23
2022.
and I think that is why Western powers
and not just the United States but many
of its allies and partners in Asia
recognize that the outcome of the
Ukraine war will be very important in
what it signals to China and that's one
of the reasons why the South Koreans the
Japanese and others uh have been working
more closely with NATO to try to make
sure that Western Unity is maintained
on that point
um I wondered I suppose on the flip side
is there a time incentive for China to
act in the next few years as opposed to
waiting longer
there's I think two things that work
here for the Chinese one of them is is
to do with their own National Power and
that's the consideration of the
so-called Peak China hypothesis has
China's economic growth uh peaked are
there serious structural problems in our
economy that may manifest over the next
10 years and uh a curve the very high
growth rates they've seen over the past
15 years
um and and also demographically are they
a substantial decline
um so that's one question you know is
there a shrinking window of opportunity
I certainly believe that one of the
reasons Vladimir Putin invaded Ukraine
last year was because not because he saw
uh necessarily thought it would be
entirely straightforward but because he
felt it would be increasingly difficult
over another five to ten years the flip
side of that is American strength um if
you look at American war games
um they all lots of them find that uh
America is at risk of losing a war over
Taiwan but what you do also find is if
they factor in
um additional Investments made in the
Pentagon particularly the procurement of
new types of weapon long-range drones
extra Munitions long-range anti-ship
missiles that this AIDS America's
ability to resist a Chinese Invasion but
none of that's going to happen for
another five five five plus years and so
from a Chinese perspective
um you know if you if you would you
rather fight the U.S force that exists
today
um without those long-range Munitions
without those New Concept of operations
and approaches that disperse their
forces across the Pacific or would you
rather fight the one in ten years time
that may have solved some of those
problems again I think that may
contribute to a Chinese sense of a
closing window of opportunity I don't
think that means that Chinese invasion
is likely I think it is actually less
likely than not in the next five years
but one can see how those factors will
shape the people's Liberation Army's
thinking and and I just finally I'd like
to know whether you agreed with that in
terms of less likely than not and
finally if we did add up there and what
do you think the chances are of a
conflict like this being contained
rather than ending up in a World War III
well look I think China has definitely
communicated that it's trying to
modernize its military with the goal of
gaining the capability of seizing Taiwan
by force that doesn't mean that they
intend to do it and that doesn't mean
that they have a deadline to do it
there's any number of reasons why China
would want to have that capability for
political reasons it gives them more
leverage over Taiwan and over the United
States to coerce them into getting the
outcomes that it wants by peaceful means
look there is a debate within the China
studies Community about
just what is the nature of China's
interest in Taiwan to what extent is it
emotional and symbolic and based on
Chinese history and the the fundamental
ontology of the Chinese Communist party
and to what extent is it opportunistic
and geopolitical and there's a
legitimate debate with reasonable
arguments on both sides but I think what
is undeniable is that any war with the
United States and certainly a war with
the United States and its Regional
allies would be devastating for China
would make it virtually impossible for
China to achieve all of its other
aspirations that it calls National
Rejuvenation which is essentially
building a fully advanced modern economy
uh in which the Chinese people are made
rich rich and influential on the world
stage so I think China is
disincentivized to provoke such a
conflict unless it thinks it's hand it's
is forced and while the peak China
hypothesis is probably true for
demographic reasons China's population
is peaking it's a economy slowing down
just because it faces a closing window
of opportunity doesn't mean it will
start a war if it thinks it's going to
lose
look I'm 29 years old I face a declining
window of opportunity to become an
Olympic figure skater but that doesn't
mean I'm going to succeed if I try uh
what we have to think about though as
not just as an American but also as a as
a network of allies and partners with a
stake and stability is how we manage
China's insecurity as it Peaks and
begins to decline China is very afraid
that the United States and Taiwan in the
future will exploit China's weakness in
order to change the status quo
fundamentally and lock in Taiwan
Independence and so at the same time as
we work to deter China we also need to
reassure China that if they don't
initiate a conflict that we will respect
their red lines and that we can continue
to maintain a status quo that is
acceptable to them over the longer term
thank you both for joining spectator TV
today
and finally Cosmo landersman writes in
this week's magazine about how he used
to pretend to be working class why did
he do it I'm joined by Cosmo now
Cosmo thank you for joining spectator TV
this week it's a pleasure you have a
confession to make in the magazine
um about pretending to be working glass
yes I did can you take us through your
journey how it came to be uh it started
back in the uh mid 60s when my parents
who were American moved to London and I
found myself after a couple of years in
a very tough comprehensive School in
North London where everyone were sort of
you know in gangs and geysers and it was
a very working class school I think
there were two middle class boys there
and to adapt it was a question of adapt
and survive I didn't want to be malt I
wanted to be like when you're a teenager
when you're a pair you want to be like
your peers and all your Maids so I
wanted to be working class too so I had
to learn very quickly how to do this
how did you I decided everyone else I
started to dress differently you see I
came from two different worlds my world
was kind of my parents world was a
middle class Bohemian Arty world and I
had a lot of friends in that world but I
had these new group of mates and they
did things very differently and I had to
learn to get the right clothes try to
get the accent try to have the attitude
the Swagger and toughness just just to
survive
and and I suppose just for our viewers
um there's quite an interesting debate
these days about what Cancer's working
class and so there's some on the left
you say it should be about what you earn
your lifestyle as opposed to you know
the roots you come from but at the time
what do you think major you middle class
compared to your peers
well I'm not going to deny there were
certain economic differences but I think
you have to go back to those days there
was there was a much more stricter
cultural division between middle-class
people and working-class people if you
went to the homes of Working Class
People and looked in their fridge you
would see certain things and if you went
to the homes of middle class people you
would see other things so that kind of
cultural homogenous thing well in middle
class homes you would find you know
Whole Foods and brown bread and all this
so this was just when the beginning of
the Whole Health Consciousness thing was
beginning Working Class People had
delicious white bread and strawberry jam
didn't worry about sugar or diets or all
this stuff it was a very different kind
of Lifestyle Trend so when you were
pretending to be working class were you
successful
that's a really good question at the
time I thought I was but looking back I
must I must have been completely deluded
I don't think I've first of all I had a
much more pronounced American accent
uh I think I only became successful when
I joined the made it into the school
football team then I was finally
accepted and while you were keeping up
your Working Class Act did it mean that
you couldn't invite friends to your
parents house absolutely not yeah I
completely but if they saw my hippie my
hippie parents it was all over
um and then at what point did you start
to have the confidence to you know to
give up the ACT
uh about 30 years later I mean I'd like
to think that I've totally given up the
ACT but I still find myself you know
when I speaking to a certain person I
might slip into the old Dick Van Dyke
accent of mine and I and I stopped can
you do it for us now because it's too
embarrassing you know it's like oh you
know just so we could and you you know
can you fix this the right Governor you
know it's just like embarrassing have
any of the friends you put on the
strongest with uh seeing you your you
know Evolution to a more honest version
of yourself
uh
uh my two wives uh were both working
class
and you know when I would go to stay
with their parents you know I would
suddenly I'd break into my Dick Van Dyke
mode and they said why are you talking
in that ridiculous way and I I just
couldn't help myself
and Cosmo during this period of your
life were you ever really caught out
well I think people had suspicions uh
but it's it I think it's to the credit
of my working class Companions and
friends as they never called me on it
you know I think they took pity on me
trying to trying to pass and they just
kind of ignored my silly accent and I
think
that's interesting one because we often
talk about you know
people say oh uh if you're working class
in the past you haven't had
opportunities that others have so there
can be a you know a desire but sometimes
suggest the other way that they you know
they push and then they're really young
and why do you think you did it for so
long I mean after school perhaps you did
at school to fit in did you then find
that you know you'd kept going along
with it and or did it fit your politics
more well I think it you've also got to
put it in the you know after I left
school the whole cultural Trend with the
rise of you know pop culture rock music
it was all it was cool to be working
class no self-respecting middle class
kid wanted to be considered middle class
we were everybody was drunk that's the
thing I'm trying to point out everyone
was dropping their ages it's
particularly during the time of punk and
then after Punk with in the 80s when
guys like the Spandau boys were very
prevalent everybody wanted to have that
it was called street cred and middle
class people struggled to have Street
credits especially if you went to Eaton
or Oxbridge do you think we still see
that today is almost a Timeless Trend
because in the labor party for example
there's definitely labor politicians who
will like to give the idea that you know
they are quite working class and lots of
people so actually you went to this
school yes I think there is that that
promise to the faking of English working
class is still going on today but I
don't know if it's so much in uh the
cultural realm the cultural realm the
middle class people you know like
Florence and the Machine people who went
to public school aren't so apologetic
they don't try and be the the whole
trend has moved away from that now I
think it's no longer as cool to be
working class or perceived to be working
class
and what do you think is the worst class
to be perceived as now do you think
there's a stereotype around being upper
class what what do you think it's the
social stereotype is oh well I think the
upper upper class and the working class
have always gotten on they always had
things in common love horses love you
know Racine gambling drinking things
like that I know it's a bit of a
stereotype I think people attend both
classes tend to look down on the middle
classes I think it's the middle class
the habitat it's an aspirational middle
class yes aspirational who want who want
to move in those circles yeah it can't
be working class or they try too hard to
be something they're not yes right yeah
I always remember
um I think it was quite summed up during
I think brexit when soon after the leave
result you heard Boris Johnson and
Michael Gove Jan has camped at both
their houses and
um you had Michael Gove come out and
I've swiped to give you Cups of Tea and
it was a beautiful I think name an
electric set you know everything was in
keeping and then you had Boris Johnson
go out and it was a sports direct mug a
mini egg mug
and also said that is the difference
between middle class and upper class yes
that's the sums it up yeah thank you for
coming on today cosme
that's it for this week
enjoy spectator TV do subscribe to our
YouTube channel click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss any
other videos thanks again for watching
and do join us again next week
[Music]
thank you